gilles lellouche
[Musique]
le hiatus ce soit pour un livre intitulé
non je ne suis pas le fils de claude
lelouch s'était arrêté de me faire chier
avec un ami fan c'est bouleversant
valeur
alors vous savez
jet la seule star à s'appeler gillain
mais je sais je sais gilles moreton mais
j'en veux tellement mes parents de
m'avoir apg ouais c'est quoi ces pages
ils s'en prennent aux bergers mais c'est
ça c'est pas un peu nom d'acteur je suis
est le frère de philippe lellouche qui
lui même est le mari de vanessa demouy
ouais vous êtes également l'ami de jean
dujardin ouais tout comme nicolas bedos
les voir une liste d'attenté incroyable
pour devenir ami de jean dujardin il ya
des bus alors allez-vous dans les années
60 il y avait ce qu'on appelait leurs
attaques alors c'était frank sinatra
dean martin sammy davis junior peter
lawford et en france on à leur attaque
maintenant notre rate pas qu'à nous
c'est jean dujardin gilles lellouche et
nicolas bedos alors pour entrer dans la
bande c'est compliqué il faut boire 3
vodka tonic parlement
raconter des blagues de cul et chaud
pays de 9 ans moins de dix minutes dans
une
revue un livre avoir eu un léger oubliez
donc ne pas être alessandra sublet
va vous êtes très copains on est très
compétent et demi même oui mais ça fait
longtemps ça fait très longtemps qu'on
se connaît tous frais donc c'est pas du
tout une amitié opportuniste ou ou
professionnels ce qu'on est on n'est pas
vraiment et vous êtes très proche de
jean donc vous d'ailleurs dans la sienne
de sodomie des infidèles oui c'est vrai
c'est vous qui faites la casca à tout
faire en vrai
vous savez que ça on l'a tiré au sort
quand même ouais on l'a fait à pile ou
face et j'ai gagné enfin sur des mineurs
jarrier du dow
disons que j'avais la meilleure position
c'est toi qui a eu cette idée en plus
non mais moi je trouve que tu as perdu
j'ai parlé de la possibilité qu'à la fin
du film il y ait cette conclusion ce ne
sera vraiment il était très très drôle
bien lieu puisque c'est une connerie
c'est que ces conneries que j'ai arrêté
de lire l olympico les voilà donc j'y
vais pas c'est comme ça qu'ils méritent
donc je veux
tu en voilà
alors j ils viennent ici ce soit pour un
film sans jean dujardin ça m'arrive de
temps en temps un coup oui mais non ça
s'appelle gibraltar c'est le vent c'est
un film de julien leclercq qui avait
réalisé l'assaut avec tahar rahim
riccardo scamarcio
celui des romans de s'occuper d'elle et
de l'énorme augmentation est bien
entendu alors c'est l'histoire de marc
duval donc un français expatrié à
gibraltar qui pour mettre sa famille à
l'abri du besoin devient aviseur des
douanes françaises et se retrouve
embarqué dans l'univers des
narcotrafiquants c'est l'histoire d'un
film assez sombres aspects c'est dur
c'est non seulement dur mais c'est
surtout une histoire vraie histoire de
marie fievet marc fiévet est acquis
c'est vraiment arrivé et qui a dédié six
ans et demi de sa vie à cette
entourloupe l'arrêt et dix ans de prison
surtout il avait un espèce de bar
restaurant dans lequel tous les
narcotrafiquants se retrouvaient pour
jouer au billard et il discutait de leur
trafic et donc on l'a on lui a demandé
de venir indique d'un 10 qu'il est
devenu convoyeur de convoyeur est devenu
lui-même dealer enfin il s'en trouvait
dans une position inouïe way en étant
censés être protégés par l'état ce qui
l'était de temps environ pas vraiment
protégé il était trahi les valeurs
étaient traduits en l'état c'est un
indic légal qui a été trahi par les
temps exactement ces tragiques comme
histoire même sens du jardin c'est bien
d'ailleurs en sortir même si on lui en
ce moment vous tourner avec lui je vais
par la semaine prochaine rue l'autre la
freine sur cette histoire du juge michel
exécuté de deux balles dans la tête et
une dans le thorax par le milieu
marseillais alors à l'époque ça avait
beaucoup choqué maintenant à marseille
c'est une mort naturelle
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu